[Music]
dalton is with us in carbondale illinois
hey dalton what's up
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve man what's up in your life
uh i just turned 20 and um
i'm gonna be honest all throughout high
school i kind of
was a knucklehead i mean i didn't say no
i didn't
by the way that comes with the deal
ken was a knucklehead all the way
through high school man
man i wasn't even a knucklehead i was
just an idiot
yeah welcome to the human race uh
yeah i um got really bad grades and all
that and
uh now i'm kind of looking more towards
the future now that life has kind of hit
me yeah i'm still left at home i've got
a paper route i make about 20 000 a year
and i'm thinking about going into the
military
so they'll pay me to go to school as
well as um
i would like to serve my country it'd be
an amazing thing and i'm thinking about
going into the police force
and it's pretty seamless to go from that
into a city police where i'm at
i don't actually need a college
education for it but um
if it's paid for you know i thought that
i might as well take it
but my main thing is my family isn't
quite on board with me going into the
army why just because they're
they're very very scared
um
mainly because
i'm not sure if i want to go active duty
yet or not oh they're just worried about
your safety
100 oh yeah that as well as um
i didn't tell you i am uh 17 000 in debt
i found you just a little too late
um i got into
a 400 car payment so dalton before i run
out of time what's your question honey
um i was just wondering uh
what i should do as far as the military
as well as um work my way out of debt in
the meantime got it ken well i got to
tell you i think i heard your heart here
and i think if you want to serve our
country i would not chase the military
option just as an education fund it's
not a bad move it's nothing moral about
it but i want you to decide why do you
really want to serve our country uh and
i think it's in that answer of being a
police officer you want to protect and
serve and so i say go uh be sensitive to
your parents they're concerned about
your safety but i think you've got to do
what your heart's telling you to do and
the good news is you can pay off that
car loan you're 20 you didn't find dave
and ramsey solutions too late you can
pay that off in no time i mean you're
making 20 from a paper route what if you
went right now in this market where
people are looking for anybody with a
pulse and they'll pay him 15 an hour
minimum wage how can you go get another
job pay that 17 000 off really quickly
and then step into the military serve
your country and then find a way to step
into a police force and protect and
serve your community i think you got to
do what you want to do
you're heading in the right way young
man
um
just move slowly and make sure you spend
a lot of time uh
beating up the recruiter for the best
possible deal yeah on what it is you're
signing up for and that you get into an
area of the military that's going to
serve your long-term dreams and serve
your educational dreams make sure you
get all of that in the package
you might even have your dad or mom
involved with you in negotiating with
the recruiter